>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> I think one thing that
you've all spoken to is,
this idea that some people see us
as like the magic of librarians.
And they almost think that they
just know all of this information
as opposed to what you're saying.
Is you're saying, you know how
to get to that information.
And I guess what I'm wondering
is, how much of that getting
to the information do you share with the patron?
As opposed to just, I'm looking
for this, or here it is.
How much do you share the journey, I guess?
>> I'm happy to show the journey.
I mean it's really great to give them the
tools and to show them, subject headings
or search techniques or something.
Because the smarter they are the better.
I mean the faster they'll get the
information; I assume you're the same?
>> I share all the time, which makes
my answers really, really long.
[Laughter].
Because I'll even tell them the things
I've looked at that I didn't find it.
So they don't go and duplicate
that kind of search.
And so, you know we're teachers
too in our own way.
And so we want people to
learn tools that they can use
in the future, not just for that one question.
>> And my team actually staffs the
chat service here at the library.
We're one of two areas that
some have a chat service.
We do it two hours a day Monday through Friday.
And one of the great things about chat is
that we then can interact live with patrons.
So when they submit us a question,
we can actually conduct a
reference interview with them.
At the same time still looking
for the information.
And pretty much share with them the
search process that we're using live
to find the information for
which they are looking.
And so we can kind of conduct
that kind of search.
And give them a real time, some real
time insight, into the search strategies
that librarians use to find information.
And I think they find that very helpful.
>> You know; I think I picked up on a phrase?
Maybe Tom's a little more
familiar with it than I am?
But this reference interview
could you talk to me a little bit?
That might uncover what that
means for me, if you don't mind?
>> Yeah, a lot of times when people
come in they, they either don't want
to tell you exactly what it is or they're
not sure how to say what they want.
And so, I call it permission to be nosey.
Permission to just ask them questions
and find out more about what they want.
Because they often don't know how to explain it.
And it, it just lets us in to
what they're trying to find out.
And I find that my biggest problems come
when I assume I know what they want.
When I don't ask enough questions.
When I don't listen carefully enough.
And I don't know if you would
add to that about the interview?
But it's asking a lot of questions.
>> Right. It's asking a lot of
questions, it's being receptive
and listening carefully to
what a person has to say.
And then based on that information, asking
the appropriate types of open ended questions.
To kind of mind down and figure
out exactly what they want.
Because more often than not, the original
question that a patron comes to us with,
is not the question that
they actually really have.
>> And, and sometimes part of that
interview isn't just getting at the subject,
but how much information do you need on this?
Do you need a full biography or is a
biographical article on one of the dictionaries
on reference going to be ok for you?
So, so also deadlines.
You need to know; how soon do you need this?
That kind of thing.
So, all those are pieces
of a reference interview.
>> Right. One of the challenges I
found and maybe you have it too?
Is that with, "ask a librarian",
it's often extremely difficult
to conduct a reference interview.
Because a person will use one of our
web forms to submit us a question.
And there's no easy way for us
to quickly clarify what type
of information they're really after.
Or how much information they're after.
So often times, we have to gage in a rather
lengthy correspondence, via "ask a librarian".
Or sometimes, I've actually
found, just picking up the phone
and calling them directly is the
easiest way to go in the situation.
>> That's what I often do.
I pick up the phone and just say "I
just need to know a little bit more."
Because I could type for a long time,
but it's just so much easier
if I could just talk to them.
And, and they're often surprised that
the Library of Congress is calling them.
But then [laughter] they realize
that it's, we're human beings too
and we are just trying to help them.
So, it, I find those really fun actually.
>> I've actually had replies when
you said "we're human beings too".
Somebody wrote back and said that "Gosh,
I didn't realize a real person was
going to be answering this question."
I think they thought that we were Google
behind the scenes and just going to do it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.